i have questions about [ __ ] tests
and uh are they like
you said you don't uh they are
numerous and you can't identify them
also
i wonder if they are formulaic or not
because i'm so deadly driven and
i like rules i don't know that that's
how i'm after are they formulaic and how
do you know they are coming
okay so let me stop you there to kind of
deal with that so all that a ship test
is
is it's a test of your competency women
women test men so they can identify
that you're the best that they can do if
if they're not going to test you
then they can't identify that you're the
best that they can do
so the fact that she's testing you is
good
the fact that she's testing you is a
good thing but
if she continuously tests you as you
pass these tests
that's a bad thing okay it's a good
thing to begin with
because it demonstrates that she's got a
genuine interest in you
and wants to establish your competency
skills
but if they're ongoing like every single
day you're having a knock [ __ ] test out
of the park
this chick is going to be exhausting
right like she either
enters your frame and supports your
purpose in your mission
or she's going to keep testing you there
are women that will that will constantly
competently
competency test men even though they are
the best that they can do
just because they're how can i put it
they're just not women that you want to
be with on a long term basis because
they're going to drain your batteries
if you know what i'm saying okay
if you are a top shelf man and she's
throwing tests out at you
cool that's fine pass them but if they
keep coming
and you find it irritating then you need
to make a decision about
how far you're going to let this carry
on and if you want to cut her off or
push her away and get her at arm's
distance or just get rid of her all
together
all right there's second questions on
frame
yeah the frame is you said bring it to
your frame
and what frame are we talking exactly is
it like
a cultural frame that the culture puts
it
or the frame that i was raised in
because okay i was raised in a very
feminine frame have you have you read
the book from beginning to end
no till chapter let me see till chapter
eight okay so what's your interpretation
of what frame is because there's a
glossary at the back of the book
i thought it's about the way you were
raised and
your values your what you believe okay
stop
stop so you see how i'm controlling the
frame of this conversation
yes right you're in my frame this is my
show you're not going to interrupt me
you're not going to talk about things
that aren't relevant to stuff that you
know
is going to be on topic with content
that i discuss
if you start to ramble then i'm going to
cut you off sort of thing so that's what
managing frame
really looks like between two different
people in intersectional dynamics
between men and women
when you're running the frame of the
relationship she always defers to you
if there's a decision to be make she's
going to defer to you if there's a car
that needs to be bought she's going to
she's going to defer to you if there's a
place that you're going to move to or
vacation
she's going to defer to you how the
children are going to be raised she's
going to defer to you
because your frame is the dominant frame
in the relationship
so that's what frame is one one person
always enters the other person's frame
in a long-term relationship or any kind
of engagement like we're having right
now
there's always one person entering the
other person's frame all right so
it's not by the culture slash
traditional country urine per se
well there's cultural things that will
drive it there's
like the way you're raised by your
parents if your dad was absent if he was
an alpha or if he was a beta like
those things will shape who you are as a
man
but that has nothing to do with frame
picture
picture this box you know between us two
right now
you know this like chat window that's a
frame
and we're both in the frame but this
happens to be my frame
okay so if you look at it that way when
you're dealing with a woman it's
it's this is my frame you know we have
to make sure she's in it and
there's certain things that you can do
to test that so you're um
muslim yeah i met this guy once and i've
told the story before and i'll probably
keep telling it because i think it's
[ __ ] great
but he was telling me how he met his
wife and the way that he would test
women was he would have them come over
on the first date he was a muslim dude
he would have women come over
on the first date to his place and make
them fold his laundry
organize his closet or just do some kind
of task
and that was a way for him to establish
frame
in that relationship before anything
even happened
so with every so with every relationship
that you enter
with any woman there's always going to
be one person entering the other
person's frame
and if you don't lead if you don't run
the dominant frame
you'll be in her frame okay
you